острів галіндис 7 кілометрів від
західного узбережжя Антарктиди станція
Академік Вернадський через два тижні
після початку повномасштабного
вторгнення сюди вирушила 27 українська
антарктична експедиція 13 полярників
мали пробути на станції рік Поки вдома
триває війна не тільки до тебе не
приїдуть А ти не зможеш поїхати якщо
щось станеться з тими Кого ти любиш
залишав батьків
бабушек брата там було відомо чи ти
зможеш повернутися додому і Чи ти зможеш
взагалі кудись повернутись
рік потому багато чого змінилося
керівник експедиції Юрій у труба разом
із командою збираються додому попереду
місяць дороги в Україну останній день Ну
скажімо так сьогодні ще ми пообідуємо на
вернадському да а вже вечеряти тут
будемо на суд від'їжджаєш і трішки сумно
але завжди
сумуєш коли вже приїхав додому Да і
пробув певний час вдома то вже якби
сумуєш за станції А зараз Якби така як
певний
ажіотаж з приводу того що виїжджаєш да
ну і їдеш додому бачити своїх рідних
близьких Ось що побачили полярники коли
повернулися до Києва
це в нас Ось так було все потріскано
це місце роботи Юрія національний
антарктичний науковий центр після
обстрілу Києва 10 жовтня торік російська
ракета впала поруч із будівлею нині
вікна замінили але всередині ще триває
ремонт документи наукові архіви сувеніри
уціліли але поки тісняться в коридорі
від антарктичних спогадів на душі
тепліше Юрій і його колега по експедиції
метеорологиня Анжеліка ганчук згадують
як промайнув рік на станції
за рахунок того що колір отак ніби
всерединку йде ніби от як на перлах
це тоді перламутрова хмара хмари лід і
сніг як справжні метеоролог Анжеліка у
захваті від антарктичних стихій ця
зимівля стала для дівчини втіленням
давньої мрії для цього довелося пройти
суворий відбір 17 людей на місце Адже
Антарктида це не лише розвага продукти
на станцію доставляють лише в літню пору
це означає що запаси свіжих фруктів і
овочів виснажуються тож раціон обмежений
коли ми їмо на станції багато білкової
їжі вона не так добре переварюється як
коли ти це робиш зеленню на собі Це
відчувається як
ти втрачаєш енергію поступово ти весь
час сонливий ти почуваєшся хворобливо
через це до того ж антарктична природа -
це завжди випробування у метеорологів
найскладніший виклик це погода тому що
ми маємо працювати за будь-якою погоди в
цьому і є полягає наша робота для того
щоб українцям зрозуміти який там вітер
от наприклад у нас часто влітку бувають
шквальні вітри які ламають дерева
наприклад для Києва це всього 15-20
метрів на секунду так штурмовий вітер
уже і
вже все летить а там наприклад це буде
до 30 метрів на секунду от в такий день
внаслідок ну Скажем так традиція Да що
ми
відкопуємо доріжку ось таку на джеті
нашої причал тому що там краще
причарювати човном залишати його на
певний час і в тому районі йому от в
цьому році в нас була висота снігу десь
4:20-4,60
А взагалі по
снігомірним рейці 3,5 м випало Тобто ми
в принципі Ну побили певні рекорди в
нашу зимівлю 27 експедиція в Антарктиду
була особливою бо вирушила на шостий
Континент коли російські війська
наступали на Київ залишити станцію на
рік без господаря означало без збитки і
для споруд станції і для світової науки
в нас би відбувся перерив наукових даних
да все-таки станція в нас є надзвичайно
стара да І в нас є певні ряди даних які
накопичуються і досліджується там 60-х
50-х років це метрологічні дані це
спостереження в даному регіоні да це є
фізичні спостереження Це даже саме на
станції магнітна обсерваторія Да яка
слідкує за магнітним полем землі і от її
дані там з 50 шостого року надходять
всесвітню мережу до 19 1996 року станція
належала Великобританії потім комплекс
споруд передали Україні британці й досі
часто навідуються в гості кажуть
полярники А от з росіянами на крижаному
континенті перетинатися не доводиться до
найближчої російської станції 400
кілометрів але від подій на батьківщині
залишатися осторонь неможливо навіть в
Антарктиді однозначна кращих новин
навіть ми вже навіть можна це сказати
слово святкували в той день звільнення
Херсону Коли це було
Правобережжя
більшості але все одно от Херсонська
область хоча б та частина людей був наша
нашого кухаря родичі були і ми знали як
от обставини
там що там відбувалося ми просто
налетіли один на одного а ти вже чув а
ти вже чула О ось такі шеврони різних
антарктичних експедицій серед інших
лотів можна було придбати на
благодійному аукціоні який проводили
полярники також влаштовували благодійні
екскурсії Люди з усього світу могли
спостерігати за тюленями і пінгвінами й
водночас допомагати ЗСУ фіксуємо коли
було відкладене перше яйце коли
з'явилось перше пташенятко Коли вони
будуть об’єднуватися так звані ясла
загалом полярники провели три збори за
перші два вдалося накопичити понад 250
тисяч гривень їх витратили на приціли
тепловізор і антидронову рушницю кошти з
третього збору пішли на автомобілі усе
для підрозділів де служать бойові
Пінгвіни полярники які пішли на фронт
люди були на сезоні приїхали на сезон
працювати там на станції і коли почалася
війна вони Скажімо так
змогли сісти тобто дібратися до України
раніше ніж повернулася попередня
експедиція то яку міняли на яхтах
туристичних Вони дісталися там Південної
Америки і вже раніше повернулася додому
і пішли вже воювати для Юрія зимівля на
Вернадського була вже сьомою для
Анжеліки першою вони ще не вирішили чи
подаватимуться на конкурс аби поїхати на
станцію наступного року головне кажуть
аби можна було завжди повернутися додому